i don't want to spend a ton of time on
this today but i got a bunch of emails
from people since joe biden was sworn in
about
what is likely to happen from the
standpoint of donald trump's second
impeachment trial which we still don't
know when it will actually
uh take place but i think it makes sense
just as a reminder that yes donald trump
was impeached a second time before
leaving office in the house of
representatives
yes it will be up to the senate to vote
to either convict or acquit in a trial
that is going to take place
at some point in time and it bears
mentioning that republican support for
convicting donald trump in the senate
trial
grew over the last few days of trump's
administration
and during the first few days of joe
biden's there's a politico
mourning consult poll released earlier
this week
where about 20 percent of republicans
now
say they either strongly or somewhat
approve of conviction of donald trump
that's up from the previous poll where
only
14 of republicans said the same thing
so support for conviction among
republican voters
is up but most republicans are still
against conviction
and of course it remains to be seen to
what degree republicans continue to
stand behind
the now former president donald trump
it's very partisan still
86 percent of democrats approve of a
conviction
uh 50 of independents strongly or
somewhat approve
of a conviction and again 20 percent of
republicans but really what it's going
to come down to
uh are republican uh senators
and it is mere speculation at this point
would mitt romney vote to convict mitt
romney voted to convict on one of two
counts in donald trump's first
impeachment trial
mitch mcconnell reportedly was pleased
with the
impeachment of trump meaning what the
house of representatives did
presumably believed to be because
it allowed the republican party to try
to create
distance between itself and the then
outgoing now former president but
just because mitch mcconnell is pleased
that trump was impeached in the house
doesn't mean mitch mcconnell
has any plan to vote to convict uh
during the
senate impeachment trial of donald trump
so it simply has to happen now
a few just very very uh basic
ideas about this some have floated the
idea that
we forget about the impeachment trial i
think this would be a disaster
um if you do a uh if if the house
impeaches they did it because they felt
they had to that's the way
impeachment is supposed to work it's a
responsibility if a president does
something worthy of impeachment then you
impeach
it would send a very bad signal about
the merely political motivations which
the the motivations are trump did
something impeachable
it will not look good if you do the
impeachment
in the house and then never do the trial
i think that that would be an absolute
disaster and it opens up the door
um to impeachment becoming a much more
political thing you know when marjorie
taylor green that
cookie q a non-congresswoman said i'm
going to
write up articles of impeachment for joe
biden before biden was even sworn in
that's the type of stuff that will start
to seem more on the level of what
happened to donald trump in the house a
week and a half ago
if uh there is no trial there must be a
trial the full process must take place
in terms of when
i actually think sooner is better i
think the longer you wait the more
the the lower the chance of a conviction
goes
so i would like to see it soon the
senate can walk and chew gum at the same
time
joe biden can get things done even while
an impeachment trial is going on that's
my view
i'd love to hear from you a shepherd
smith gave a very interesting interview
to christiana montour the other day
shepard smith former fox news anchor
for a long time was like the sole voice
of reason on fox news
and when he was there we wondered does
shep understand what he's doing does he
understand the context of
crazy in which he is offering something
that looks more like
the news on fox news channel and this
interview he gave to christian amanpour
is fascinating and it confirms that shep
smith was very much aware
of what he was doing there and um he
said
that a lot of his presence on fox news
was specifically to serve as a
counterpoint
to the wackiness of what we were seeing
on fox news he called it injurious to
society
what was happening there and uh you know
this plays into our discussion about the
future of right-wing media in the
post-trump era
smith says in this interview that the
falsehoods from his colleagues on fox
news
eventually became too much to bear but
that his point was to inject reality
take a look at this
i thought it was important that i stay
there because i knew that i was grounded
in that philosophy
and and working toward that promise and
if you feel like the fox viewers were
getting miss or disinformation i was
there to make sure that they got it
straight
there were a lot of others in there who
were trying to do the same thing
but i thought to just abandon it
and to deprive those viewers of it
wasn't just me i mean there's an entire
team of people getting the news to the
air
to to deny them that with the thought
that they might replace it with opinion
instead
seemed a little selfish this is actually
very interesting
uh staying at fox news because if you
leave they replace you with someone
worse
we applied that same thought to the
trump administration
in many cases we said you know fauci
clearly is disgusted with what's going
on
but if he quits and they replace him
with someone even worse is the country
better off or worse off and that
that's the exact analysis that shep
says he was doing when at fox news
christian amanpour then
asks whether shep smith accepts that fox
perpetuates division
and perpetuates lies and shep gives a
very interesting answer i want to play
the entire thing for you
and and i don't know you know you can be
proud of what you did
but i wonder whether you also feel now
that you're at cnbc you see how a whole
different ecosystem works
um whether you accept that fox news
in the opinion sphere and you know in
other rupert murdoch
enterprises you know perpetuated
so many of the divisions the lies the
conspiracies
um the support look at sean hannity
going up and you know
doing campaign rallies for president
trump
so blurring the lines is to be the
propaganda
arm of the republican party i just
wonder what
what you think about that now
well i i feel the same way about that
now that i did then
and my goal was to just keep the
blinders on
and do my job to the best of my ability
and
was i i'm always concerned
when people want opine all you like
but if you're going to a pine begin with
the truth and opine from there
and it's that that deviation from that
that has
has caused me the greatest concern and i
and i believe that when people
begin with a false premise and lead
people astray that's injurious to
society and it's the
and it's the antithesis of what we
should be doing those of us who are so
honored and
and uh grateful to have a platform of
influence
have to use it for for the public good
and i slept very well
i don't know how some people sleep at
night because i know that there are a
lot of people who
who have propagated the lies and have
pushed them forward over and over again
who are smart enough and educated enough
to know better
and i i hope that at some point
those who have done us harm as a nation
and i might even add as a world
will look around and realize what
they've done
but i'm not holding my breath so that's
a really interesting interview
and from the outside we didn't know what
shep's perception was of what he was
doing
and some say shep was still bad
because he was on a network generating
them profits which were then funneled
into continuing the disinformation and i
sympathize with that
shep was a cog in the wheel and you
could even make the case that shep
provided cover to fox news you could say
shep
being there one hour a day
five days a week provided cover to fox
to say no no no we have all sorts of
different perspectives
um but the reality is you know fox would
exist either way
and if you want to say are we better off
with fox having
one hour of shep smith versus zero
or replacing shep with someone worse
yeah you know i mean he shep knew what
fox was every time he was cashing the
checks
and um i don't know what that means
if shep's goal was to provide a counter
narrative which he did
he could have left earlier and gotten
the same paycheck elsewhere and in fact
now he's getting the paycheck at cnbc
it's not that clear to me
that shep did something wrong by staying
when he was providing a counterpoint now
another perspective is
he should be credited for remaining true
to his role
despite so many people around him at fox
news selling themselves out and that his
responsibility
was to stay as long as possible and for
for as long as fox would allow him to
stay and not fire him which they
ultimately didn't ultimately he quit
although maybe he was pressured we don't
know he's doing a good thing
and um i i can sympathize with different
perspectives on this but i think much
like
with the fouchy example if fauchi quit
when trump talked about injecting bleach
and
started attacking fauchi publicly if
fouchy quits then
he's replaced with someone that is
probably going to do
far more damage and probably lead to
even more deaths than we've already seen
during the coronavirus pandemic so faux
stayed and it was probably the right
thing to do uh much the same way
i think on balance we are better off
that shep stayed longer rather than
leaving and being replaced with
you know imagine if shep leaves a year
and a half ago
or whenever it was and they replace him
with maria bartoromo
the country's worse off there's no
question about it so i'm curious to hear
your thoughts on that
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
and we have a fantastic friday show
planned for you today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is member
supported get the world
famous bonus show and commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
by signing up at joinpackman.com
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right it's been a very very big week
and much has happened we have a new
president
we have a new vice president donald
trump fled washington dc and
shame on wednesday um
all very exciting and many people want
to comment so let's go
to what we call the phone lines even
though they're really more like
internet tubes at discorddavidpakman.com
discord let's go to our friend scott
from pensacola even though every time i
the last time we went to scott from
pensacola i have a friend scott in
pensacola he's never actually called in
it's some other
scot in pensacola
scott in pensacola you're on the air yes
you got me
yeah excellent
so the inauguration
yesterday um what do you make about
uh them i guess the people on the right
um crying about how garth brooks decided
that he wanted to show up for
joe biden but had a scheduling conflict
last time i couldn't care less yeah i
mean listen i i mentioned this during
the live stream earlier this week of the
inauguration
where in 2016 in 2017 trump wanted garth
brooks
and garth brooks said sorry i have a
scheduling conflict and it wasn't really
clear whether he did
and then garth brooks was invited this
week and he said i'm doing it and i'm
doing it as a unity statement not as a
political statement
and of course many of us wondered was it
really a scheduling conflict in 2017 or
did he simply not want anything to do
with
with donald trump i don't know the
answer but to the extent that
right-wingers are focused on it
i don't care it's such a minor issue
do you think you was successful in
making a unity statement with it
i was garth brooks successful or was the
biden inaugural a a strong
unity statement uh the inaugural more so
yeah i mean i listen here here's the
thing
joe biden did so much more
on wednesday than he anyone deserved
given the divisive and weaponized
disinformation nature of the last
four years now given that biden did it
is it likely that we're now going to
have unity with these obstructionist
republicans
no but biden did it just because it
won't work
because the republicans won't go for it
doesn't mean biden was wrong to say
let's come together and i'm everybody's
president so i think biden did a good
job i don't think it'll go anywhere
and one last question before i'll let
you go what do you think
just sort of as a normal person
um i can do or generally people in the
audience can do
to kind of keep um colleagues or friends
from
sort of tuning out and going to brunch
as i've heard it put
i mean i think i think the the most
important message
is nothing's happened yet biden
now can do stuff but nothing's happened
yet and of course he's gotten some
executive orders done so things are
starting to happen but
i think the message needs to be the last
four years we didn't even have a shot at
getting anything done
now we have a shot at getting things
done but imagine that whenever you get
the ball back in football
you stop playing because you think you
score points by getting the ball
you would be very wrong once you get the
ball you've got to score the points
that's where we are now
gotcha well thanks for your time my
pleasure scott from pensacola
always great to hear from our friends in
pensacola
let's go next to erin from california
erin you're on the air
aaron from california you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can
hey awesome well my question is kind of
like
a bit more broad i guess because so
after obviously i mean we can all agree
like
the last two three months has been like
an insane amount of like just
pure disinformation from the republican
party
yeah across the board so i'm wondering
obviously this is kind of a long shot
but like would it be possible for like a
type of regulation
that we kind of say like hey like
all x types of like new upcoming social
media companies or established
you to have like either like a chief
scientific officer
or like some type of panel on these
companies that goes through like
what's in the media what's being what's
being spoken about and reported and see
like
what is the obvious types of
disinformation that like these companies
can try
and stop no i don't see any shot at that
whatsoever i don't think there's any
legal basis for it and i also don't
think it's the right way to fight
disinformation i've said this before
in different formats or with different
framings and i'll say it again
the solution to disinformation
conspiracy theories
anti-science anti-vaxx delusional q anon
fox news oan newsmax rush limbaugh mark
levin alex jones to all that stuff
the solution is better educated people
teaching media literacy early creating a
culture where people
have a healthy skepticism when they are
given information by something that
maybe the news or maybe just looks like
news i don't think that we i i just
i don't believe and i've seen no
evidence that we can
regulate our way out of the
disinformation ignorance crisis yeah
yeah for sure i mean like because i
think the big thing is like
i mean we've seen like just everything
escalate in terms of disinformation
so so exponentially over the last few
years
that it feels like at least to me but i
don't know like obviously yeah we could
i definitely agree with the route of
like educating the populace over time
but it feels like there's so many people
that it would take so long it would that
here's the thing here's the thing
it took ford i've been i've been
repeating this a lot because it's
important
to understand it took 40 years for
things to get this bad
it's going to take a long time to fix it
and and we have to be okay with that we
just have to improve because
the only way you you quickly change
something as big as what you're talking
about is via dictatorship and we don't
want to be a dictatorship
and so i think we just have to concede
it's going to take a while to fix this
and that's
it it's not that it's okay we'd rather
fix it more quickly
but we don't really have a choice in a
democracy
yeah of course all right well thank you
david
i appreciate it thank you so much uh
there is uh
another perfect phone call for lack of a
better term
let's go next to oh there's just so many
people that want to get on here
why don't we go to is it mari
or marie from the san francisco bay area
mari or marie please unmute yourself and
then i'll be able to talk to you
mari or marie please unmute you were on
the air and this is the last chance
all right mari or marie is donezo
let's go to logan from san jose
california logan you're on the air
hi uh can you hear me all right yes i
can
thanks david i'm also from the bay area
so i'll make up for the last person
beautiful um my question is on the
joe biden's covet relief bill yes i
noticed
there was the 15 minimum wage added in
there i'm kind of wondering the purpose
of that
because it doesn't seem like now is the
right time with small businesses already
looking to make payroll or
not being able to make payroll and uh it
seems like it's only going to slow down
a
time sensitive bill you know i didn't
see that let me see
um let's see here biden stim i didn't
know
that that was part of biden's stimulus
let me take a look i'm pulling up an
article about that
biden uh called for a rescue package of
1.9 trillion
and we have all of the the things
increasing the federal minimum wage to
15
per hour oh that's interesting you know
it's not it's not clear to me
that he's calling for that to be in the
bill and quite frankly i don't even know
if you can do it that way
uh but i'd have to look into that more
that's it's an interesting question
i didn't think i thought he was saying
part of my economic plan is a 15
minimum wage i didn't think he wanted
that literally in the coveted rescue
bill
okay uh you know i admittedly didn't
look uh too closely at it
i thought it was a part of it but i i'm
not 100 sure
right i know it was part of his
presentation but that's a really good
question whether
you would include a minimum wage change
in the bill
and listen let me put it this way even
if he is thinking of putting a minimum
wage of 15
in the coveted relief bill that's gonna
be negotiated out
it's not gonna get past this part of
covet relief that i can assure you
got it got it um one other quick
question i noticed uh
today in the inaugural address and joe
biden's been really
pushing for for unity you know reaching
across the aisle and uh
between parties i'm wondering what that
what's that going to look like in your
opinion
oh it's a complete impossibility i i
mean
i think it's great that joe biden is
using this language and to the extent
that it will appeal to voters
to hear joe biden say even after all
this i'm everybody's president i think
that's great
um how are you going to have unity with
mitch mcconnell
uh lauren beaubert marjorie taylor green
you know there's just no way there's no
it's just not going to happen
but i think biden's doing the right
thing by saying it because
until they show him they will be
obstructionists
biden should go forward saying let's
work together and then we'll see what
happens
yeah that's so that's i wasn't sure how
it was possible yeah
no it's not it's not but it's good for
biden to say it
all right that's all i got for you today
david thanks all right thanks very much
appreciate it
um let's see we're hearing from so many
different people here
uh why don't we go to uh skyler from new
york skyler from new york you're on the
air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
awesome so uh i was wondering obviously
for the better part of a year we've been
talking about let's just get the ball
back let's just have the
win and then we can push him left um how
do
we make the next four years productive
in that we're not just comparing
everything biden does
to what trump did but to actually push
him left and pressure him and educate
people to vote
in in more of their best interests well
the first step is we have to compare
biden to his campaign promises
and you're absolutely right that if we
simply say this is how it compares to
trump
everything will essentially be better
maybe we'll stumble across something
where we say wow
biden somehow is even worse than trump
on this one
issue i i think those issues will be few
and far between if any
but i think the first step is we
as progressive media have to remind the
audience
not just about what trump would have
done but what did biden promised that's
the start and if
if we forget that then we don't stand a
chance and then beyond that
obviously with the midterms uh and
hopefully
growing influence for the progressive
caucus in the house of representatives
there will be a continued pressure on on
joe biden but
the most important thing is let's keep
let's hold joe biden accountable to his
own promises
yeah because like i've already seen when
it comes to like people he's named in
his cabinet or
the way that he's gone about just like
trying to work with republicans that
he's already getting a lot
of pushback from the left and then i'm
also saying like guys let him actually
be
president for a week before we start
criticizing him yeah and
on working with republicans i think all
there is
so far to criticize is what is there to
criticize
biden has said he wants unity and he
looks forward to making progress with
his friends across the aisle like he
likes to say
there's nothing wrong with him saying
that it's naive if he thinks he's going
to do it because they're not going
to they will be obstructionist clowns
but i think it's silly to criticize
biden for saying it i think what biden
would be wrong to do
is to think that he'll be able to
negotiate with these people when they
when he won't but so far i don't i don't
think there's any criticism that would
be levied
just for biden saying he's going to try
it i think it's great to say let's try
to work together and get things done
as long as he doesn't end up
compromising on what he campaigned on
yeah i just don't know the most
productive way to raise the bar because
if you look at the obama administration
it's easy to compare it to george w
bush and say obama did a tremendous job
but obviously
if that was the case it wouldn't have
led to the election of trump well that's
why i think it's
remember on paper biden's campaign
platform
is well to the left of obama's i i would
argue that joe biden's
platform and his campaign promises are
the most progressive of any president
that has become
president now we have to hold him to
them if we do
if biden does the stuff he promised
then we're going to be moving the
overton window left
if biden comes back from his promises
and just
operates as a centrist then we're going
to be extraordinarily disappointed
absolutely yeah so i guess you know all
we could do at this point is
wait and see and make our voices heard
in the most productive way possible
absolutely and make your voices heard
through your
your local representatives by i mean
your
members of the house and senate that
represent where you live
yeah well thankfully my representative
is centered kathleen wright
so i have a lot of work to do okay yeah
that's an uphill battle
all right thanks all right my friend
thank you so much uh let's take a quick
break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we're going right back to the discord
tubes for more phone calls in a moment
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
want to send the david pakman show a
dollar make a pledge
of as little as one dollar a month at
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
let's get back to hearing from you via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to adam from los
angeles california adam you're on the
air
hey david uh so i actually wanted to ask
about
um daca and the dreamers sure um
obviously it's been a roller coaster for
them
um and you know now with a slim majority
in the house and senate
how likely do you think it'll be for not
only people who
are in daca but people who maybe
narrowly do not qualify
um to get some relief i'm confident that
the current daca participants current
participant doesn't seem like the right
word those who currently qualify for
daca status
i think that in relatively short order
they are going to be taken care of now
in terms of expanding daca to include
more people i think there's more of a
question mark around that and it's
really too early for me to have a strong
sense of of how likely it is that daca
will be expanded
totally yeah because i know even as
recently as 2019 um the the dream act
um obviously got blocked by mitch
mcconnell in the senate yeah
um and didn't even be it wasn't even
brought to a vote but i know the bill
itself has always had
bipartisan support so hopefully you know
something can happen there
you know the the disgusting reality is
there are despite bipartisan support
there are likely republicans who may
want to stand in the way
merely to deny joe biden an
accomplishment on this and that's really
sad because we're talking about people's
lives being at stake here
oh yeah livelihoods may be better said
you know
i i think it's disgusting and i guess
the hope is that um
you know something can get done about
that you know would they need
um any bipartisan support even to pass
it
you know that's a really interesting
question it's
without really reading more about it i
don't know
how much can be done by simple majority
how much can be done by executive order
and how much would need 60 60 votes and
so
i i don't have an answer on that at this
immediate moment i think it's something
i'm gonna have to read up on absolutely
well thank you so much for your time
david
my pleasure great to great to speak with
you uh we are hearing from folks via
discord
at davidpakman.com
discord let's go where do we want to go
next
uh why don't we go to jason from phoenix
arizona next
oh and jason uh jason left um
oh by the yeah very very very important
okay let's let's go next to
i believe it's shannon from japan and i
put am i pronouncing that correctly
shannon from japan caller from japan
you're on the air
japanese caller last opportunity
that's too bad would have been would
have been interesting let's go next to
leishan
from new york city lei sean you're on
the air
hey david how are you i'm doing good
uh and what ways do you think
uh president joe biden would be superior
or inferior to a president
bernie sanders oh well let's see
inferior would be that biden is to
bernie's uh
right and i am to biden's left
and so i'm closer to bernie than i am to
biden and so from a personal standpoint
i think
bernie um would would of course be
a more progressive president and i would
like a more progressive president than
joe
biden in terms of ways in which biden
may
may uh be superior to bernie
it really remains an open question but
the argument that's been made
is biden has the ability
despite not being as progressive to
accomplish more
both because uh of that very same reason
that he's seen as
less of an extreme leftist although
neither bernie nor biden are extreme
leftists in any way
whatsoever and maybe biden's
historical alliances and relationships
with the centrist wing of the democratic
party as well as moderate republicans
could allow him to get more done he
won't get things done
that are as progressive as what biden as
what bernie would want to do
but bernie being more progressive if he
can't actually get things done is of
questionable use
that's the argument right and i'm not
saying it's the right argument but
that's the argument that's being made
and
we'll have four years now to figure it
out
okay uh follow question what big issues
do you think biden is going to
be known for after he's out of office
whether it be infrastructure
foreign policy et cetera first of all
covid
kovetkov and kobe what does donald trump
like to say i
i think that um if joe biden can
navigate
us out of this and we come out of it um
understanding the un unrecoverable
tragedy of the virus but we come out of
it with
uh not only a stronger economy but
hopefully also
with treatments or vaccinations for
other conditions on the basis of the
rapid advancement of the
mrna technology platform uh and if
if into that we can wrap up a green
infrastructure deal which biden
campaigned on
i think that those have huge potential
to be biden's legacies
and then you know you really never know
right when trump was elected nobody
thought his legacy one way or the other
would depend on a global pandemic
but in huge part it has so i think it's
just too early to say beyond that
all right uh also how are you liking
discord discord's great
yeah i know i we i love discord
all right david uh great talking to you
all right my pleasure uh great
great to hear from you um okay
davidpakman.com
discord is where we are let's go to alec
from the united kingdom alec you're on
the air
yes that's it i literally just joined
realized i would be the first that would
be first up
i'm sorry about that um hello yes i'm
from the uk um
i guess my question would be mainly
about
coming in because obviously violence in
baden's
just got in with kamala um looking
forward to
2022 with the i think i'm not sure which
seats go up i think it would be congress
and senate right
so before 2020 is there some third voice
in the background right now when between
you and i
it might be i don't know so every two
years
all 435 house seats are up for
re-election
and one-third of senate seats so that's
what's up in 2022
okay so i guess the question would be do
you think
do you think that republicans would have
like a high chance of
reclaiming lots of their seats
especially after trump's after party
i i did i did a video about this
actually typically
when the when the white house switches
party the next midterm is bad for the
winning party
but i think that circumstances are very
different this time
the senate seats up for re-election
aren't particularly bad for democrats
and it's a real question my hope is that
a lot of these q and on
conspiracy theorists like lauren
beaubert and marjorie taylor green
my hope is that they will be one term
flukes and that they will lose in 2022
so i think it's quite plausible that
democrats do okay in the midterms
okay um are there any moderate
republican season grabs do you think
um democrats have any chances of
flipping those
yeah i don't have the senate list in
front of me and there's many in the
house
but we'll we'll look at that in more
detail as we get closer to the midterms
no worries man anyway have a good show
hey but i'm curious what are you what
are you doing are you cooking or what
are you working on right now
i'm doing that i mean i just um right
now i'm just reading
you're reading my dissertation all right
and you're not in a you're not in a
factory or anything
it could be just how bad my microphone
is i'm using a
i'm using um head like basically
something
here got it laptop mic so that's
probably why
all right alex thank you so much i
appreciate the call
no worries thank you thank you david
pleasure absolute uh absolute and
complete
complete pleasure um let's talk to a
couple of other people why don't we
i mean it's like we're here right why
why would we just end right now
let's go to stephanie from london
stephanie from london you're on the air
or no i'm sorry that's stephanie from
long island not london
sorry stephanie am i on
yes you're on stephanie oh my god sorry
this is so surreal for me
hi it's nice to verbally meet you
pleasure um
uh i just wanted to get your opinion um
just because
uh i've been hearing from a lot of like
pundits you know that the capital
riot was uh similar to
like 911 on how they felt you know with
um you know i guess a terrorist attack
um
you know it with considering you know
the actions
taken after 9 11 with like the patriot
act i guess i just wondered
your opinion on um you know
constitutional law
um like so let me see if i can i want to
make sure i
i've seen floating around that there are
some
folks who i guess really they seem more
libertarian than anything else who
who are warning that much like we got
the patriot act
after 9 11 that we might get something
similar because of the capital riots is
is that what you mean stephanie yeah um
you know just everyone at least the
conservatives i've seen have been
complaining about their constitutional
rights being violated
even though it's not technically a
constitutional
violation to lose book deals and uh be
kicked off twitter but
i think with the patriot act um you know
at what to what extent
should um you know constitutional law be
i guess waived uh for in in
sort of compromising national security
well it shouldn't then it's not
and uh so so as you rightly point out
losing a book deal because of what you
did
on january 6th this josh hawley did that
that's not a constitutional issue it's
not a free speech issue it's nothing
other than businesses making decisions
um when it comes to the fbi putting out
wanted posters and saying here's the
people we're looking for if you have
information let us know
there's no constitutional issue there um
that is something that's been around in
the united states for hundreds of years
and and it's no
problem uh fears of some kind of
crackdown on privacy because of the
january 6th riots
aren't um they're they're not misguided
i'm not seeing evidence that there are
attempts to do that
stephanie so i would hesitate before
jumping too deep in that
to see if there's actually such attempts
that are going to be made i
i think that's kind of how i would
categorize the different follow-on
effects of the riots
yeah i guess i like considering like joe
biden
um chuck schumer like these are all like
democrats that you know were
for the patriot act i guess i just sort
of
am concerned that you know after
acts of terrorism you know the
constitution
could be used like could sort of like
you know be sort of go out the window
yeah the question is a good one because
that has happened in history but
remember that much of the right doesn't
even see what
happened on january 6th as terrorism
and so i i don't think that what is
being
uh proposed as a possibility is actually
going to happen
okay yeah all right well thanks so much
for
um speaking with you i really appreciate
it big fan thanks stephanie great to
hear from you i i appreciate it as well
um let's see who else we we can talk to
here
how about oh i don't know
there's some very interesting folks here
why don't we go to cooper from
south carolina
uh hello david it's my first time
calling
um so i have a couple concerns about
medicare for
all okay so with the current system
um i want to go to a doctor appointment
with a specialist doctor
and it's gonna take me like six months
to uh get seen because i'm on a waiting
list
okay this is a real scenario you're
currently on a waiting list that's a six
month waiting list
yeah and what specialty is it
dermatology
um no it's actually a neurologist okay
having some like uh nerve issues um
so my fear is that in a system
uh that's medicare for all perhaps the
wait times would be much longer
and i'm concerned that um like
for example if the waitlist was like a
year a year and a half like that would
make the care a lot less valuable
yeah so um i was wondering like
what what's what do you think about that
yeah i actually just did a video about
this a week and a half ago
called um won't what was it something
like
won't medicare for all mean everybody's
gonna try to get health care and it'll
gum up the system so there's a couple
different things first of all
uh as you are pointing out we already
have wait lists
and sometimes people have to wait for
things and so one aspect of this is when
you change a system
some people still have to wait it's
sometimes different people than the ones
that are waiting now and ideally
weight would be commensurate with
inversely related to the degree of
urgency for the visit that's that's
number one
um number two you also over the long
term
would be likely to reduce the need for
specialist visits
by treating a lot of things early a lot
of people now
forego going to a primary care doctor
at all because they either don't have
insurance or don't want to pay their
co-pay or whatever the case may be
so something that could be dealt with
without a specialist early becomes
something that then you have to go to a
specialist for
and so i think that it's not uh these
are complex issues there's no question
and there's examples of when you expand
access you do
uh increase the demand at emergency
rooms and it increases wait times
there are examples of that i'm not
denying that and these are complex
issues
but generally speaking generally
speaking
it's it's much more nuanced than simply
well if a lot more people
have health care the waiting list that
every specialist will go up
yeah um i was thinking maybe um at least
for like
uh like you were saying like the primary
doctors
maybe you could have a medicare for all
system for that but then also have like
a
public option for like more of the
specialty doctors just that way
like if you actually need to get seen
for something you might be able to
yeah i've never heard of medicare for
all plus public option i've heard of
medicare for all plus private insurance
for those who prefer it
i think in most systems medicare for all
makes the public option not necessary
but uh that's something i that would be
interesting to look at
okay thank you all right thank you so
much i appreciate it
very interesting questions that's going
to do it for us
for today but we will take calls again
now in the biden era thanks to everybody
who joined me we will take a quick break
and be back with much more right after
this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is now on
instagram as david pakman show
check out behind the scenes pictures
memes funny stuff and more
follow us on instagram at david pakman
show
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
let's get into audience questions for
the week our
first post trump set of questions
in the joe biden era there's something
in the air
that's just seeming a little different
uh but let's get right into it and
a lot of these questions really go to
sort of seeking to understand
where we are as a country right now and
i think that these all tie together very
well
the first one is david now with trump in
the rear view
how did trump change the country and how
did he not and and i think this is
really the perfect question to start to
understand what happened
donald trump did not as as
near as i can tell create racists or
racism
create xenophobes who want to stop
immigration from so-called [ __ ]
countries
what he did was he coalesced these
groups of people
and he made them more comfortable being
public
about it the things that used to be
whispered
behind closed doors by people who had
some sense that while this is what i
believe
i recognize i'll probably be looked down
upon in most circles if i say it out
loud
they were welcomed into saying these
things
out loud but it's important to
understand that that is a change
not ch not creating racism may be an
area where there was not a change under
trump
but the racism being more open is a
change
under donald trump and along those lines
the changes we really saw
under trump include of course degrading
the public discourse degrading
what counts as acceptable political
debate
and what counts as acceptable in a
political campaign
in terms of particular types of insults
not only about your political opponents
but
you know ridiculing disabilities
ridiculing
uh deceased members of the military
there was nothing beyond
the pale uh be uh it was beyond the pale
that there was nothing that trump
saw as off the table i think better said
in terms of what and how you can
criticize
others and the change trump made and
we'll see if it gets changed again but
it could be an irreversible change
trump removed whatever was left of the
idea of american exceptionalism we
really sucked
during the last four years in ways that
many americans
wrongly but many americans previously
thought
would only happen in other countries or
only happened in other countries and it
turns out that
what we learned is that the united
states is just like any other place
really terrible corrupt people can get
into power
that corruption and weaponization can
get into
law enforcement it can get into the
military it can get into all aspects of
government
it can interfere with science it can
infect even
you know nasa and all of these other
things and that
is a change now the things that
didn't change during trump's presidency
are also cause for concern
what do i mean by that well how did
trump get
to be the republican nominee and
ultimately become president
the structure of anti-intellectualism
and reactionary politics not based in
fact
are partially what got donald trump into
power that hasn't changed
in fact i would argue it's worse than
ever and it's been particularly
weaponized
by the explosion of right-wing extreme
media like newsmax and oan
and q anon stuff and others uh
the electoral college got trump into
power
that hasn't changed so another trump
could come into power again
i think if there is what is the most
important message that could be taken
away from the trump presidency because
there are many
um checks and balances aren't nearly as
robust as we thought they were when you
have a madman in the white house
uh elect you know we have all these
different takeaways
the most important takeaway now that
we're looking forward
must be nothing has changed about what
got trump into power in the first place
if anything it's worse as we saw by 75
million people voting for trump in
november
and just as easily as trump got in i
would argue it is even easier for
another trump to get into power
that's the top takeaway so yes
fix gerrymandering get rid of the
electoral college
find a way to democratize the senate
which is so anti-democratic
you've got to deal with campaign finance
put dealing with climate into the law
rather than leaving it to the whims of
political administrations
there's such a long list of things that
have to be done but
if we don't recognize that until we
actually deal with
the culture that got trump into a
position where he could win the
republican primary
and eventually the the uh presidency it
could happen again and that's
very very scary david what are the best
arguments against
democracy isn't it just perfect
as we eclipse the trump era
that the best argument against democracy
is donald trump and and what i mean by
that is this is the platonic argument
against democracy
left to the masses the masses often make
stupid decisions left to demand to the
masses
lots of ignorant people get to decide
this i'm not coming up with this and i'm
not saying this is my
perspective or that i want to get rid of
democracy but
look at plato's republic plato viewed
democracy this takes me back to my days
in philosophy 101
plato viewed democracy sort of like a
interme a liminal look that one up a
liminal phase between oligarchy and
tyranny
and plato and i'm sort of summarizing
from memory here
to plato democracy was probably
too fond of freedom and equality
and indulging people who have no
business influencing how a
culture society economy or country
should be run
and that there are costs to that there
is no way in full democracy or we don't
really even have that in the united
states but in something point pretending
to be full democracy
to ensure that we have competent
administrators
and people in power that's a risk of
democracy
um there is not enough in most
democracies to really crack
down on the elites and those in power
who are squeezing the average people
we've seen that in american democracy
and
the idea of plato again i'm summarizing
was that in democracy
eventually things point to
people falling for some kind of
strong man that they believe will make
things better
but points us in the direction of
tyranny and of course
that's exactly what we saw under donald
trump
so the the downsides of democracy are
the last four years and it should really
be
you know for for for many people
learning about this stuff
it was here was plato's idea
and it's sort of like a thought
experiment i guess although there are
there are
historical examples of it happening we
have one now in the united states we've
seen the downsides of democracy which is
that ignorant people
put an authoritarian buffoon in power
and he starts moving us in the direction
of authoritarianism he was a wannabe
dictator
now from a practical standpoint aside
from democracy is good versus bad
one of the flaws uh of
of a of a democracy is that particularly
for really large countries
it's tough to come up with a cohesive
strategic direction for the country
because you have the constant second
guessing and flip-flopping of power
and this is why when we talk about well
trump
says he had to do executive orders to
undo the bad things obama did even
though executive orders were bad under
obama
trump had no choice and now biden has to
do executive orders to undo the terrible
things that
donald trump did and there's this
constant looming
uh reversal of what is done
because of the system we have and
because there's always some election
looming i know this is crazy but
the members of congress in about six
months have to start campaigning for
re-election for 2022
they get two-year terms and so that that
is always there
so a lot of this now goes beyond
the idea of democracy but when you have
a sys when you have a world in which
many of the problems we're trying to
solve are more than two-year projects
or they're more than four-year projects
but we have
every member of congress up for
re-election every two years
and every president up for re-election
or a presidential election every four
years senators every six
uh you're not really creating
circumstances
that uh benefit the longer term
issues that we as a as a society as as
as humans need to deal with so
i am not anti-democracy but there are
arguments against democracy and the best
ones
all come from what we saw over the last
four years david who is responsible for
the destruction of the republican party
the first question is has the republican
party been destroyed it's not clear
most trump most republican voters still
support trump
so it remains to be seen however yes
trump lost the white house in 2018
trump's nonsense lost the house for
republicans
in 2020 trump's nonsense lost the senate
for republicans so that's true
but i don't think the vast majority of
the blame
should go to trump it's the voters who
put trump in
who were radicalized by the right-wing
media
whose influence grows and grows and
grows
and it was abetted by the republican
officials who stood by and mostly let
let trump do his thing so yes
trump's actions were bad and trump's
actions are responsible for him
losing in 2020 and trump lost them the
house in 2018 and the senate in 2020
but the real responsibility lies
with those who allowed trump to get in
in the first place due to
voters who voted for him and republican
elected officials who stood aside
and right-wing media that chair
cheerlead the entire
thing and in a way you can sort of say
that this started with the
radicalization
under ronald reagan in the early 1980s
it was accelerated by newt gingrich in
the mid 90s who
newt gingrich really brought in this
style of politics
that was own the libs i mean now that's
what it's called they didn't call it
that in the mid-90s but newt gingrich's
idea was
just obstruct democrats for the sake of
obstruction
uh oppose democrats on everything for
the sake of
opposition and that's how we went from
nixon
who created the epa to
jim inhofe in the senate holding a
snowball
claiming it to be evidence that global
warming and climate change
aren't something we need to worry about
so there are feedback loops here and it
can be hard to say exactly where it
started and what's responsible
trump is hugely guilty for damaging the
republican party
but trump doesn't get to be president or
even republican nominee
were he not enabled by republican voters
and right-wing media
and those are the very same republicans
who now are partially radicalized
because donald trump's way of thinking
about politics
was a signal boosted by right-wing media
over the last four years
so when i really think about blame in
terms of the future of the republican
party which is still a question mark
trump was and has been exactly who we
believed that he was now a lot of
right-wing voters didn't believe it
but we knew who trump was he doesn't
care about anybody but himself
he ignored what is his real job and
instead
lobbed attacks at enemies didn't do the
things he had to do mishandled
every major challenge and then when he
lost eventually which was the right
outcome based on his actions he blamed
everybody else for that as well
and uh when we say who who is ultimately
really responsible it is trump
but it's right-wing media and it's
republican elected officials
who could have stopped this a long time
ago and it's republican voters as well
um and that leads us to what does a
rebuilt republican party look like
i don't know how the republican party
comes together to rebuild
to the extent that they're now out of
power in the house senate and white
house
how do they rebuild without dealing with
the q anon oan newsmax trumpy
wing i don't know the answer to that but
we have time to look at that it is the
beginning of the biden era
come monday i will have a report for you
about
has joe biden gotten done the things he
said were week one and day one
priorities
this is a different phase but we will
see what the future of the republican
party is
stay with us for the bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com